guess what the minimalists are going on
tour with a live version of the
minimalists podcast
and i want to invite you to join us for
a night of less find your nearest city
at the minimalists comm slash tour we'll
see you there podcast has bad words hey
hello simpletons what's up yo
so there we got a text message Ryan this
week someone was like how could you
possibly how could you call your
audience simpletons I'm like well Ryan
and I are the head simpleton right
really yeah exactly vice president and
president simpletons right it's so like
for those of you don't know the like the
long term inside joke is like we
registered the minimalists comm because
the simpletons comm was not available at
the time but right simpleton means
gullible or foolish and by the way we're
all gullible or foolish with respect to
something and I think that is really
gonna come to the forefront today I just
love how you responded you said
something like if I have to explain a
joke it doesn't make it funny but here
it goes I hate I hate explaining my
jokes but here goes here's the thing
obviously we're being silly we're
actually trying to reclaim this word
simpleton because to some extent right
Ryan you and I don't take ourselves very
seriously especially when we talk about
very serious topics and we're going to
talk about a serious topic today one
that is a fairly contentious topic today
we're going to talk about what's healthy
and what isn't healthy and we're going
to do that with our guest today dr. Paul
Saladino is back Paul thank you for
being here it is so good to be here
thank you so much for having me good to
have you you can check out his podcast
it is called the fundamental health
podcast now Paul we usually answer
voicemail questions that people call in
and we we give responses but instead of
doing that to start I wanted to talk
about a few things here first off a
disclaimer I am NOT a doc doctor you're
not no I'm not dr. Dimas however we have
a medical doctor here with us today but
I think it's probably prudent to say you
should always consult your doctor before
hand but I also realized that
ters often fail us I've been very failed
by the medical system I've been failed
by several doctors and Paul you are a
medical doctor and you have been
discontented by the sort of traditional
system and you've sort of had a
reawakening that's true it's true I mean
my path to medicine has been circuitous
before I was a physician I was a
physician assistant in cardiology and
what I quickly realized as a PA in
cardiology was that the system that I
was a part of tended to treat symptoms
rather than getting to the root cause of
an illness and I think before the
podcast we were talking about healthy
obsessions and unhealthy obsessions well
I think one of my healthier obsessions
is understanding the root cause of
things maybe in another life I could
have been an engineer I too think about
medicine with an engineering mind more
than a traditional medical mind and I'm
so interested in what is causing
something that is the most interesting
piece of a puzzle for me and when you
can understand that and see all of these
complexities that are built on that root
cause that crux shift and change it's
such a satisfying thing but what Western
medicine seems to do and I don't think
this is the fault of any physician it's
more of the paradigm and the zeitgeist
or the actual way that we think about
problems in Western medicine which is
not really a systems perspective when
Western medicine tends to do is kind of
work up here with the symptoms work in
the branches and the leaves and say oh
here's your symptom here's a medication
for your symptom right yeah well we are
taught in medical school is which pill
to give for an illness and what an
illness is called
we are very rarely challenged with what
is causing that illness and so that is
where my discontent arose and that was
why I went back to medical school after
being a PA and thus began the second
part of my medical journey yeah now your
new book which comes out on February
25th is called the carnivore code and so
I know for some people they that they
even hear this term carnivore or
carnivore diet or carnivorous and they
think of like someone who is is
obviously just eating meat and that
seems like well first off we've been
told that you know plants and vegetables
are the healthiest thing we can eat in
fact our good friend rich role has been
on this podcast three or four times now
once with you and so we wanted to bring
you back on your own because rich has
been on here but
he's one of the healthiest people I know
he's a big advocate of a plant-based
diet he is also a vegan and he's an
athlete he's in his 50s and he is wildly
healthy in fact I would argue that most
of the healthiest people I know are have
have a large number of plants in their
diet however you've written this book
but it's also not I mean it is not
dogmatic in the way that many carnivores
are many vegans can be it seems to me
you take a non dogmatic approach can we
talk a little bit about about this book
but also what what convinced you that
plants might not be that good for us
yeah there's a lot there I love that
that you're highlighting this question
and I think this is gonna be the
question for this podcast what is
healthy and how do we become healthy I
was on the podcast with rich and I think
that a lot of health goes beyond food
we're gonna talk a lot about food today
but most listeners will be aware that
health is more than food it's lifestyle
it's how we we live our lives and I
talked about that in the book as well
that's kind of one of the side points
that returning to an ancestral way of
living an ancestral lifestyle is
something that we can pretty much mostly
agree is a healthy thing for humans the
main point of contention is how did our
ancestors eat and how should humans eat
but beyond that if we just put that
aside for a second we see lots of
commonalities between healthy peoples
indigenous peoples peoples who are not
in modernized countries in terms of
lifestyle that probably facilitate
health in many ways things like exercise
time with community family meaningful
relationships meaningful meaningful
careers meaningful passions in their
lives as they pursue sleeping and dark
environments not over excessive to blue
light you know lack of exposure to
toxins and non processed food okay so
those things most people can agree on as
healthy and health promoting and as
we'll get into a lot of people who do
that also choose to eat plants but
there's this new movement of people like
myself or kind of challenging that idea
and saying wait a minute wait a minute
you know meat is healthy as well and I
try not to be dogmatic about that and
well dink into what we'll dig into all
of that as well but so I went to medical
school after
being a PA and I had an autoimmune
disease so I had eczema and eczema is
connected with asthma and people might
say oh that's just XML it's not a big
deal well my eczema got pretty severe at
times to the point that I had super
infection on my skin with impetigo and
it limited me from doing many of the
things I like to do specifically jujitsu
martial arts basically being outside and
exercising
I had it she patches on my elbows and
knees times I've had it on my face and
my neck my lower back so skin conditions
these autoimmune skin conditions like
eczema which is connected with asthma
and these atopic medical conditions can
be pretty debilitating for people and
Western medicine basically hands you a
steroid cream and says here's your
steroid cream this will fix it and it
will but does it treat the root cause
and it doesn't and I'd use steroid
creams in the past when I was in college
I had a very severe flare of eczema used
a steroid cream and it caused sleep
disturbance and mood disturbance and
weight gain and I was not satisfied with
that sort of a paradigm for me with my
autoimmune disease so throughout the
process of having an autoimmune disease
I was trying to understand what is the
lever here what is causing this and I
think it's food for a lot of people this
is one of the most important messages
that I seek to advance in my work
regardless of the diet we choose I think
that humans making intentional choices
with regard to food is awesome and
laudable and I hope that Western
medicine as a whole will wake up to the
fact that food is a big lever and health
and disease and that collectively we can
start to look at which foods might be
triggering disease and people
specifically autoimmune chronic
inflammatory diseases like eczema so in
my own life I was trying to figure out
what are the foods that are triggering
this for me and I went through a process
of kind of elimination a lot of people
do these elimination diets they're very
powerful
some people eliminate meat some people
eliminate dairy some people eliminate
plants and what I found for myself was
that when I went raw vegan many many
years ago I lost a lot of weight I lost
a lot of lean healthy glucose
controlling muscle mass he lost a lot of
weight it wasn't it wasn't good weight
it was muscle weight all right yeah so
for people that are listening to the
podcast I'm a pretty lean guy
I wasn't overweight at the time I lost
veins like muscle mass I lost muscle
mass one big main right you know you
said glucose managing muscles I didn't
realize muscles help manage glucose like
that absolutely so muscle is important
for glucose disposal when we are
ingesting glucose when we are even
ingesting any food it has to do with
insulin sensitivity which is kind of an
esoteric concept but when we lose muscle
we are both weaker we are more
structurally prone to damage in our
bodies and kind of break down or
fracture and we are likely to be less
insulin sensitive because the muscle is
where a lot of the nutrients go it's the
glucose disposal organ the muscle and
the fat tissue play kind of delicate
roles they have this interplay this
dance that controls our metabolism and
our insulin sensitivity so losing muscle
is generally regarded as a very bad
thing yeah both in young people and in
old people there's a condition known as
sarcopenia which is loss of lean muscle
mass and we're not just talking about
big muscley men like yourself even
though I mean you're not like a
bodybuilder but you are you're very lean
and you're very fit but we're talking
just everyday men and women need to have
a certain level of strength that's
optimal for their overall health and and
exactly and that is correlated with a
certain amount of lean muscle mass what
we know is that as we lose muscle mass
when we age we become more prone to
basically death
you know we become more susceptible we
become weaker and cachexia which is what
happens with cancer is the loss of
muscle mass the loss of tissue in the
body that's generally what kills us with
cancer is this loss of lean muscle mass
you can think of lean muscle mass is
kind of like that that energy bar and a
video game like muscle is kind of like
your life force it's one of the life
forces that you have in a video game and
if you lose muscle mass that life force
bar goes down in a big way it's not a
good thing to lose so when I went raw
vegan trying to affect my eczema I lost
25 pounds of lean muscle mass and at
that so I mean I'm 170 pounds right now
at that point i was a hundred and forty
five I was pretty skinny yeah and
everyone would say you're too skinny and
I'd say no no I'm good the eczema didn't
get better my mood didn't get better my
sleep didn't get better my energy didn't
get better my GI system got worse anyway
I had Horrell
gasps not fun to be around me you guys
would not have wanted to sit around me
in a room like this when I was a vegan
no bloating gas issues with the GI
system and so okay this isn't working
for me let's move on to the next thing
and I heard oh wait you were getting a
lot of fiber in your diet we're told
that fiber is a good thing exactly and
in fact I remember 2014 we were on tour
Orion we were out in Salt Lake City and
I was having some some gut issues and I
went to see a GI doctor and they just
prescribed Metamucil right Sunni mosques
yes and I'll tell you actually it did
help me become more regular because I
was relatively constipated and so it
seemed overall like a positive thing
although I found out since from our
close friend Tommy wood we have a shared
friend Tommy it was talking about how
maybe that's actually bad for the
mucosal layer and the gut so you don't
seem to think that fiber is necessarily
a a good thing I don't know are you
saying it's a bad thing I think it
either is neutral or bad and certainly
in some clinical situations we see
vegetable fiber being quite worsening
for our conditions and exacerbating some
people's gas bloating constipation and
diarrhea when they add fiber so in the
book there's a whole chapter on fiber in
fact there's really one and a half
chapters on fiber I'm kind of debunking
the myths around fiber the specific need
for humans to have fiber to be regular
to have healthy bowel movements that's
clearly not the case yeah there's a
study that I talked about in the book
where they took 60 people they divided
them into three groups and everyone in
the study had idiopathic constipation so
they had constipation that was kind of
unknown idiopathic is a word we use in
medicine which means we don't know
what's causing it
right so people in this group had
idiopathic constipation they had one
group that had normal fiber one group
had reduced fiber and one group had zero
fiber zero fiber in the diet and the
zero fiber group 100% of those people
completely resolved all of their
symptoms of gas bloating pain and
constipation with zero fiber and so if
you really dig into the medical
literature surrounding fiber it's not
clear that fiber is beneficial to humans
now in some people fiber is not going to
be harmful but in others especially
people who seem to have over
growth of the small bowel we call this
condition small intestinal bacterial
overgrowth which has to do with probably
loss of diversity in the small intestine
fiber can be very worsening or very can
be a real problem in terms of
symptomatic management and doesn't seem
to be feeding the right populations in
the gut so it can be a problematic thing
at that time in my life I had a lot of
fiber and that to me
led that for me led to a ton of gas and
bloating and I just could not have been
healthy because an olfactory way I was
in a nightmare it was just a night is so
interesting how just different diets
affect people differently it's it's like
for for rich role like his vegan diet is
great for him but for you it makes you
bloated and gassy it's funny I have so
anecdotally when I ate red meat I get
backed up like I'd so I tend to take
more fiber if I'm eating red meat is
that is that because I'm combining the
red meat with something else or is it
and you probably can't solve my you know
this this view right here but I'm just
curious I'm throwing this at you because
you're a doctor so I hope you don't
charge me for this appointment but yeah
so I mean what do you think man I mean
is it so when you take red meat like for
me with I take red meat and I eat that
it's usually with like some veggies or
with a salad or something maybe a sweet
potato something like that I do notice a
severe difference in the way that my GI
tract
operates yeah it's quite interesting I
think it may have to do with a couple of
factors so what I talked about in the
book which is about the carnivore diet
which is a diet where you eat only
animal foods and you avoid meat or avoid
plants because of the toxins in it is
that when people are eating more meat
they can develop constipation if they're
not getting enough fat and so I wonder
if there's something happening with your
specific GI microbiome or your gut are
you eating lean meats a lot of times as
humans we're not used to eating fat or
fatty meat anymore
or as evolutionarily we appear to have
hunted the fattiest animals and sawed
those out so that's a great point no so
when I eat when I eat like a steak if I
do I used to do filet mignons a lot
which is super lean which is pretty lean
I don't do those anymore because I have
found I like the taste of you know just
something that is a little bit fatter
you're like
prime rib but what I do with the prime
rib is I like the fat if it's chewable
but sometimes you just get the gristle a
fat that I don't eat so by default
actually make it a little bit leaner
than when it comes because I'll leave
those fatty parts out
that's interest so what you're telling
me is eat more fat with the stick
because when I eat ground hamburger meat
that's the only exception is when that
doesn't really affect me interesting
that's because it has more fat in there
I would think could it could have more
fat depending on how how the fat from
the chuck roast that's ground into the
ground beef is is marbled or yeah which
fat isn't that yeah yeah interesting
okay cool now we talked about toxins and
so instead of doing voicemails today I
went over to Whole Foods and I bought
this magazine called heart health and if
there's not one prime rib on the cover
this is going to be a very YouTube
centric episode so Jordan can put this
up on on YouTube here but so we're
looking at this and I figured Paul what
we could do is just talk about this does
look healthy to me this looks actually
looks like a picture of health this is
the special eating well edition right
and so if you're just listening to this
at home I'm gonna describe the cover to
you I see a bunch of plants some fruits
and some vegetables I see limes and
grapes and avocado and and asparagus and
broccoli and blueberries and it looks
like maybe some sort of beets and it's
an eggplant raspberries some peppers
some strawberries and tomatoes and maybe
that's an orange and some carrots and
some corn so for all this analysis this
is a vegan it's all vegan it does appear
to be although throughout it's not the
whole magazine is a vegan so I thought
we'd just start with the cover and then
we can flip through here and you can
tell me what is because this looks like
the picture of health to me what is
unhealthy about this this cover so this
is I love this conversation if we back
up for a moment you said this looks
healthy and we think about where we get
those ideas of health from there's so
much conditioning that we have as humans
that gives us the narrative around this
this is almost Shakespearean nothing is
eating either good or bad but thinking
makes itself right yes like
we are thinking that these foods are
healthy this is the picture of health
that we are given this is the
programming we are given as westernized
humans for the last 70 years and we'll
probably get into why that's important
with regard to how misleading
epidemiology studies can be which are
observational studies but it is so
interesting that you find this to be
what's healthy right right and if they
were a steak on the cover many people
would say that's not healthy right
that's red meat red meat isn't healthy
they would say cholesterol that they
would say that yeah too much saturated
fat and fat in general that they would
say higher risk for cancer they would
say carcinogens are you saying all of
that's wrong all of that is wrong all of
that is wrong okay heard it here first
and we can talk about why it gets a
little deep it's a nuanced thing and I
talk about all that in the book there
are a number of chapters debunking the
myths surrounding why red meat will not
cause heart disease will not cause
cancer will not cause decrease longevity
will not cause any of those things and
you you seem to back that up there's
hundreds of studies that you reference
there are hundreds of studies that will
show that and the problem here is that
when we are thinking about what foods
are healthy we are generally told that
with epidemiology studies and this is
where I think a lot of the consternation
and misconception arises epidemiology
studies are not experiments they are
population surveys that seek to
correlate health outcomes with recalls
of dietary preferences over the last
five to ten years does this make sense
so what I'm hearing you say is like
these are kind of biased
they're absolutely susceptible to bias
and confounding income so in the book
there's a graphic that I have reproduced
that correlates the divorce rate in
Maine with the per capita consumption of
margarine and we will see we will see
that they are highly correlated more
than 99% correlated okay okay
does that mean that as the divorce rate
in Maine declines margarine or as
margarine declines the divorce rate in
Maine declines does that mean that
margarine was causing divorce in Maine
right
this is the absurdity there's other
correlations we can draw between the
number of movies Nicolas Cage appeared
in and suicides by hanging right so that
actually makes it like so
no offense Nicolas Cage we really think
that do we really think that you know
it's possible but this is this is what
epidemiology does it creates a
hypothesis sure and so much of what
we've been told regarding what is
healthy and what is unhealthy is based
on observational studies which were
never meant to infer or create the
judgments regarding causality mm only
interventional studies can tell us about
causality interventional studies are
studies in which we make a we have a
control group like the constipation
group and we take one group and we do
one intervention we take another group
we do another intervention and we watch
them closely over a short amount of time
epidemiology our population surveys and
so what we see and this is true there
are many epidemiology studies which show
that the more fruits and vegetables we
eat the better our outcomes does that
mean that fruits and vegetables cause
those outcomes we can't say it's a
possibility we can generate that
hypothesis but there are many other
alternative hypotheses this is margarine
and the divorce rate in Maine another
hypothesis which is felt to be quite
likely by many individuals is that
because we've been told that these are
healthy foods
who eats healthy foods healthy people
people that do other healthy behaviors
oh yeah right yeah so is it non-smokers
non-smokers more likely to exercise more
likely to be in the Sun higher
community-made higher socioeconomic
status more regular doctor visits for
for mammograms and rectal exams and
colon cancer screening and so when
people are doing these surveys they will
often these surveys will get these
epidemiology studies will often get
reposted to the Internet they make great
headlines there was recently one in the
Journal of the American Medical
Association kind of on the flip side
showing the more meat you eat the more
risk you have of cardiovascular disease
and again it's an association these are
not they didn't take a group of people
and
feed them more meat and then see more
cardiovascular disease they took a group
of people and they surveyed them and
they said how much meat did you eat over
the last 10 years and they looked at the
people who ate the most meat and they
had more cardiovascular disease hmm so
this is potentially confounded by
unhealthy user bias or on the flip side
of this eating well cover with a coterie
of vegetables and fruits are people who
are eating meat we have been told that
meat is bad for us for the last 70 years
so who eats meat people who are rebels
this is James Dean right these are
people who ride motorcycles who smoke
and how many people do you guys know
that eat steaks without bread right that
eat steaks without french fries that eat
steaks without other sugary foods yeah
we're talking about a standard American
diet here si D sad right and and in the
standard American diet what's Ryan and I
definitely grew up on oh my god we were
the two fattest kids in our school so we
met we were fat little fifth graders I
was the only kid fatter than Ryan yeah
in fifth grade oh how the tables have
turned and I mean we would eat
cheeseburgers as a snack so it was it
was me now even the quality of the meat
was very questionable right it was
certainly corn-fed and probably factory
farm and definitely not organic and and
what it was being fed was a bunch of
pesticides as well and plus all of the
the pesticide ridden sort of products
that went along with the meat the bread
the the cheese I'm saying that in air
quotes because American cheese I don't
think that's even cheese yeah and and
then of course all the the salsas that
go with that in the side of french fry
well cheese fries cheese fries what's in
the sauce oxidized vegetable oils right
mayonnaise is made from canola oil corn
oil soybean oil so epidemiology can't
distinguish they could survey you and
you would say I eat a lot of cheese
burgers and they're gonna say
Joshua's fat he eats a lot of
cheeseburgers the more cheeseburgers you
eat the more meat you eat the fatter you
get okay
yeah epidemiology is not meant to do
that it's meant to generate hypotheses
which we then test with interventional
studies the interesting thing is that
interventional studies with meat have
been done and I talk about these in the
book
any guesses what they show you know it's
not harmful it's not harmful for humans
and why would it be when we think about
it through an ancestral evolutionary
lens and I talked about this in the very
beginning of the book humans have been
eating meat for the entirety of our
evolution as hominids and we can get
into this in a moment many
anthropologists many scientists that I
looked at that I read that I talked to
believed that the human brain exploded
in size not literally but figuratively
about two million years ago because we
began eating meat at that time there's
evidence for hunting practices these old
while these eschew liyan tools so these
by facial tools that kind of look like
stone knives evidence for butchering and
hunting it all happens about 1.8 to 2
million years ago with the arisal with
the with the appearance of Homo erectus
and then suddenly if we look at the
cranial vault size brains get bigger and
they just kept getting bigger and bigger
and bigger over the next 2 million years
they went from 500 CC to 1500 CC the
point that I advanced in the book the
thesis is that eating meat made us human
mm-hmm why would something that has been
a central part of our evolution be bad
for us that's just sort of the intuitive
perspective right now and then when we
look at interventional studies we don't
see that either so there are studies
that I talk about in the book where
people were they replaced carbohydrates
in the diet of any source with 8 ounces
of meat so they ate less carbohydrates
these could be things like vegetables or
bread or pasta and they added 8 ounces
of meat so half a pound of meat and they
looked later on weeks later to see
inflammatory markers immunologic markers
DNA damage all of them went down they
all went down so how do we reconcile
this right when the epidemiology studies
like the one from JAMA say you're gonna
eat more meat that's correlated with
more cardiovascular disease but the
interventional studies say meat doesn't
harm you in fact it looks like it's good
for you and we know intuitively that
makes a lot of sense because we've been
eating me throughout our evolution it's
incredibly nutrient rich and we can talk
about that as well there's a real
discordance here and within medicine
it's widely accepted the interventional
studies always trump epidemiology but
this is the message we've been getting
from this magazine yeah epidemiology
epidemiology epidemiology and the very
missed
leading sandy rocky unstable foundation
of this is healthy user bias and
unhealthy user bias and I think this is
at the root of why so many people are
confused and why there are so many
conflicting studies I'll just add this
and then let you guys weigh in on all
this the other thing about epidemiology
is that we can for almost any
epidemiology study that shows a
correlation between eating vegetables
and improved outcomes we can find
another that does not show it similarly
with eating meat for every epidemiology
study that shows that with eating meat
we have there's a correlation with poor
health outcomes there are conflicting
epidemiology studies which show improved
outcomes with eating meat there are very
large cohorts in Asia of over 200,000
people and they show that the men who
ate the most meat had the lowest rates
of cardiovascular disease and the women
who ate the most read meat had the
lowest rates of cancer Wow how can this
be right how can this be are we really
that different genetically no it's a
different narrative
I think it's reflecting a different
narrative in Asia meat is associated
with prosperity and affluence and so who
eats meat people who are doing the
healthy behaviors people who have more
money just like the people in the US and
the westernized world so those are the
people that's the same group of people
they're eating meat in one place and
they're eating more vegetables in
another place and so this is why it's so
murky and we have to really look beyond
the epidemiology or realize that the
epidemiology can be so misleading that's
crazy
maybe we can like just dig a little bit
deeper with these studies so what what
is it about like these foods on this
cover that are unhealthy what is it that
lets let's do let's do that because
we're gonna do plant toxins now but but
but also here's the thing we we know
that 97 percent of people listening as
roughly are omnivores meaning they both
meat or animal products and they eat
plants and maybe about three percent are
our vegans and and and then functionally
zero percent or percent are the only
carnivores in this room right here's the
thing you don't eat any plants is that
correct well I don't need any plants
okay and but in your book you also and
we'll get into the the carnivore dish
thing we can talk about grass-fed vs.
factory farm we can talk about
all of those things but let's talk about
the plants that are on this cover you
don't tell me why you wouldn't need
let's go just go through a few of these
dig yeah these are very delicious
delicious and nutritious nutritious by
the way between a vegan and a carnivore
died just for deliciousness yeah
definitely vegan might be yeah yeah I
can have cake all day on it that's right
in Oreos and Pillsbury Dough products
all right so so let's let's look at this
so a fig is delicious but what's wrong
with eating a thing so I wanted to get
into that I just want to frame this all
with something you brought up and I
appreciate this so much I try so hard
not to be dogmatic about this the main
messaging that I see to advance with
this this pretty contrarian idea of a
carnivore diet is number one like we
just kind of talked about meat is not
bad for humans and has been a central
part of our evolution is super
nutritious to remove meat from our diets
is to deprive ourselves of some major
nutrient sources you would say some meat
is bad for humans though because if it's
a factory farm cow that has been fed a
bunch of pesticide a corn and soy and
and then we have that that that Cal that
is slaughtered and you know it's not
grass-fed but but also maybe it's it's
charred really darkly extra well done
carcinogen that there are there are
times where meat is bad for you correct
quality matters
quality matters and when I'm saying meat
I'm thinking the three of us are a tribe
we go out and hunt me that's well raised
you know that's wild or from a
regenerative agriculture farm right at a
bail Campo and we go to bail Campo we go
to white oak pastures in Georgia we go
these places where they're doing it
right and we can talk about that okay
the other part of the messaging that I
hope to share with people is that plants
are not as benevolent as we have been
led to believe and if we just think
about the predicament of plants let's
just put ourselves in the shoes in the
shoes of plant and plant shoes and plant
roots shoes real quickly and then a lot
of what's on this cover will become more
clear cool so in the book I offer this
thought experiment we're at the beach
and I say Joshua Ryan I'm gonna bury you
guys up to your nan neck in the sand I
dig a huge hole I put you in there I
pack you in super tight and you're like
whoa this is like way tighter than I've
ever been buried in the sand I can't
move
and your head is there you had to stick
enough I'm gonna let him paint your face
like a soccer ball
no I doing that hmm and all of a sudden
this busload of irascible hungry
irritable six-year-olds from the soccer
team shows up on the beach how do you
feel feel feel like I'm about to be
kicked in the head you feel a little
vulnerable yeah right okay plants and
animals have been Co evolving for 450
million years during that time plants
have always been rooted in the ground
there are not really that many mobile
plants I I mean they happen in cartoons
but plants can't really get up and run
away from animals and right so plants
need animals to move their seeds around
through fruit sometimes so plants and
animals need each other and animals have
always eaten plants there are
herbivorous animals right mm-hmm but if
all plants don't develop some sort of
defense mechanisms they're just going to
get eaten up immediately and they will
be extinct right their genetics will not
get passed on there has been a constant
arms race between plants and animals
throughout the entire coevolution of
these two kingdoms of life and you can
see it happening you can see plants
evolving toxins animals evolving defense
mechanisms plants evolving toxins
animals evolving defense mechanisms
interesting and this is true I mean if
you look at botanical chemistry there
are thousands and thousands of toxins
and plants all sorts of plants in the
leaves and the stems in the roots
especially in the seeds mmm and we can
talk about fruit that's a little bit
different situation but if you look at
plants they are riddled with toxins and
there are there are more overt
demonstrations of this with spikes right
cacti roses they say get the heck away
from me I'm gonna put a spike out there
right now plant toxins which are
essentially known as phyto alexinnz are
plant chemical spikes right so people
may be aware of that why I like so I see
a pineapple here on the cover if I eat
too much pineapple my tongue starts
burning there is a there's a digestive
enzyme in there that can bother the
tongue pineapples are fruit so it's
probably not as toxic as many of these
other things although it's the most
delicious fruit and that's why it has
that sort of exterior cover on it Wow
it's like its own sort of cactus and oh
I didn't realize it was a digestive
enzyme so like we had to digest the
pineapple
before it digests us almost almost but
we can look at this and I can show you
some pretty significant plant toxins the
peppers are the ones that jump out at me
and I'll talk about those but we wheat
spices all the time right but they like
a hormetic stressor will get it not so
oh man so many rabbit holes to go down
so if we look at thee if we look at many
of the compounds in these two peppers
the red peppers and the orange peppers
here they have lectins which are
carbohydrate binding proteins and in
pretty good cell cultural experiments
these lectins the lectins the
carbohydrate binding proteins and many
of the other fight OLX and toxins in
these peppers are known to open the
tight junctions in our gut mm-hmm these
are from the nightshade family
nightshades are particularly virulent or
particularly bad in terms of this in our
body they have been shown repeatedly
whether it's tomato or eggplant or
peppers to do this to really irritate
the gut lining hmm and the goal here
from plants is clear it's saying don't
eat me like starting to irritate your
gut lining what you're saying is because
they don't have legs to run away this is
how they effectively run away this is
how they effectively run away or
effectively manage their diplomacy with
animals if we look at the way that
animals consume plants they don't
consume plants unabated they don't
consume plants excessively they'll move
from one plant to another plant to
another plant there are documented cases
which are myriad regarding mass deaths
of animals who are coy stirred in
grazing areas and forced to only graze
on a limited number of plants hmm and
they get over consumption of toxins and
they die whether they're alone wild
buffalo or bison or elk there was
recently something I read about giraffe
over consuming acacia because they
didn't have anything else and the toxins
overwhelming systems so it's very clear
that even herbivorous animals are aware
of this and have had to develop systems
to detoxify plants this is part of the
messaging that I hope to advance in the
carnivore code with the book is that in
some people these plan toxins aren't
really poorly detoxified and some plants
can be more toxic than others right I
think a lot of people will have a sense
of this they'll say you know what I eat
oranges in my mouth gets red or I think
when I eat chocolate I get a rash that
is a plant toxin abducting someone
negatively that's what happened to me
with my eczema and that was kind of my
story that I
more and more plans and finally when I
cut out all the plants the eczema went
away
at long last but never did until I cut
them out so maybe I'm someone that's
particularly sensitive to these things
you might be able to eat some plants you
might be able to eat other plants but in
general we should not forget that aside
from fruit and that's a special case
we'll talk about plants are generally
not our friends mmm they're beautiful
and they may or may not have some
consciousness and they're what we'd love
to look at them and we know that our
parasympathetic nervous system is
affected positively the sort of relaxing
nervous system when we're around plants
but a plant doesn't want you to eat it
you know I think we know that
intuitively with most plants like if you
walk outside right now and you you see a
palm tree you don't go up and start
eating the bark and yet these plants on
this magazine in particular that I mean
not only they're gorgeous but these are
all things that I put in my body and I
generally would feel pretty good about
it right so so why didn't you put
broccoli in your body broccoli is a
great example so so broccoli is a
Brassica vegetable these are the family
from an ancient mustard and on the cover
of this there are some things which are
fruit some things which are roots some
things which are stems and leaves and we
will differentiate between them broccoli
is sort of a stem in a leaf right it's
kind of the flowering portion of an
ancestral mustard plant it's the same
plant as kale it's the same plant as
cauliflower the same plant as Brussels
sprouts collard greens etc etc now
greens which were told her the best
thing for us oh yeah best thing for us
so every day when I used to when we were
living in Montana in fact when I first
started dating back she loved that I
always had a like a a little ziploc bag
full of spinach in my pocket every day I
would go and bring it to wherever I was
going so I could add greens to like my
burrito bowl or something we should talk
about spinach spinach is a particularly
nasty one because oxalates
spinach is super high in oxalates which
are a dicarboxylic acid that's a waste
product in humans that can be present in
ten to 100 times the amounts in many of
the vegetables and they sort of do
chelating roles and vegetables where
they hold onto minerals but in human
bodies they're known to accumulate in
tissues in the book I talk about
oxalates and I'll get back to rock
broccoli in a moment in the book I talk
about oxalates being deposited
i Royd they've done autopsy studies and
over 70% of people had oxalate deposits
in their thyroid oxalate doesn't have a
physiologic role in the thyroid we see
oxalate deposits in breast tissue there
are many research that that have
concerns that oxalate deposits and
breast tissue may trigger precancerous
lesions where else do you get oxalates
almonds almonds beets turmeric spinach
and all the things I love navy beans so
and they also are associated with kidney
stones yes the most common type of
kidney stone is calcium oxalate right
and there's a genetic condition called
primary hyperoxia urea where someone
makes more oxalate because of a
deficiency or a defect in a biochemical
pathway but we can create levels of
oxalate in our body that are as high as
someone with that genetic problem by
eating large amounts of oxalate
containing foods you're not gonna like
this one no chocolate oh man pretty high
in oxalate right man so that's the
spinach thing right like and then
there's a whole my chocolate because
it's a bean it's so it's a it's a seed
seed right it's a seed and what is
fermented uh-huh right so the
fermentation actually gets rid of many
the polyphenols which are also toxins
we're just kidding we're told that the
polyphenols are good I know right
exactly so there's a whole chapter about
this in the book about how they've been
widely misconstrued so I'll talk about
broccoli which has isothiocyanates which
are not a polyphenol but will illustrate
this mechanism and we'll get into our
Mises okay so many exciting rabbit holes
to go down yeah yeah anyone help
ourselves yeah so broccoli is this
ancestral mustard plant it's a flowering
plant right and throughout evolution
broccoli has developed this ingenious
booby trap you ever seen Goonies yeah
what he traps yeah broccoli has a
compound in it or a family of compounds
in the family of brassicas called
glucosinolates a lot of big words coming
out you guys I'm sorry glucosinolates
right I already feel like ten times
smarter glucosinolates are inert they
just kind of hang out in the broccoli
they're like a booby trap waiting to be
sprung when you chew broccoli or an
animal chews broccoli you break the cell
membranes and there's an enzyme called
myrosinase in the broccoli it combines
with glucosinolates specifically guca
rafen in the case of broccoli and make
isothiocyanates it's kind of like when
you combine the two things with
superglue you got this chemical reaction
so why is that bad for me because it's a
booby trap right because it makes
isothiocyanates like so for Athene so
for a fain is a phyto election but I'm
told so for a fain is good because of
the hormetic response exactly so then we
have to unpack hormesis and what were
your why you're told that okay so so for
a fain works hold is good for you you
probably have been told so far Athene is
an antioxidant right yes it's completely
false and no one would disagree with
this no one in the scientific community
can debate that so for a faint is a
pro-oxidant then we have to unpack
oxidation-reduction okay a pro-oxidant
is a molecule that creates free radicals
in the human body probably not a good
thing mm-hmm other pro-oxidant sled
mercury alcohol cigarette smoke I'm not
good things right so for a feign creates
free radicals right we've been told it's
an antioxidant because people are trying
to kind of whitewash the actual system
and kind of simplify the science the
reason you are told so for a feign is
good for you and this is where we get to
hormesis is because by being a
pro-oxidant it activates a system in the
liver called the nrf2 system which
increases your endogenous production of
glutathione and other endogenous
antioxidants these are molecules that
are part of our human biochemistry that
actually do the dirty work of taking
care of irascible free radicals okay so
for a feign does not do that directly
and so this is the concept of hormesis
so for a feign increases glutathione
right that's all well and good until we
expand the lens and we realize number
one that not only is so far a Fame doing
that but it's also circulating in the
human body and doing all sorts of other
negative things so when we go to the
grocery store to the pharmacy to get a
drug right hopefully not many people are
taking pharmaceutical drugs but if
people are on statins or antidepressants
it comes with a package insert which
lists all of the other side effects yes
we are all familiar with the notion that
if we introduce a foreign molecule into
the human body it may do one thing that
we like it to do but it's also likely
going to do many other things that we
don't want it to do yeah these are
collateral effects plant molecules have
the same thing of course they're their
molecules right plant molecule is a is a
molecule plant so for a feign is a
molecule it could be you know
synthesized and
sold to you in a grocery store as a
pharmaceutical and if it would have to
do that they would have to give you a
package insert that says this molecule
also competes with iodine at the level
of your thyroid and may create
hypothyroidism if consumed in excess
without adequate iodine in your diet
well you guys ever seen the pictures
from rural regions of the world where
people have the big necks the yeah yeah
that's from consumption of
isothiocyanate containing foods without
adequate iodine in the diet hmm these
are people who eat cassava which is a
widely grown root or other root
vegetables that have other
isothiocyanates that inhibit iodine
production in the thyroid
where are you good iodine I get iodine
from fish or egg yolks or there's a salt
out of utah redmond sea salt that has a
decent amount of iodine interesting so
alright so these these booby traps which
lead to free radicals that circulate
throughout the body what what is what
are bad about these free radicals oh
these free radicals do well free
radicals are bad in general free
radicals are good in small amounts okay
our body uses reactive oxygen species
for signaling they're bad in small
amounts okay what I was taught they're
bad in largemouth look I spoke okay okay
what I was talking about first there is
the fact that so for vein has all these
side effects that were never told about
okay right and I'll just explain that
and so when you take a medication you
expect that the benefits are going to
outweigh the risks gotcha
so the benefits that we are told of a
sulforaphane are that it's a [ __ ] Matic
that's going to increase glutathione but
what if I told you that there are many
studies that show that you don't need
that so for a feign to have any extra
glutathione that you can make all the
glutathione you need by jumping in cold
raked lakes and rivers by being in sauna
by being in the Sun and by exercising
then when we actually look at the net
effect of fruits and vegetables they
don't give us more antioxidants that is
where the story falls if there's more
side effects and there are benefits
exactly there are more side effects than
there are benefits it's not a unique
benefit so the benefits do not outweigh
the risks and there are lots of risks
and all the molecules have different
risks we can talk about many different
molecules okay the sulforaphane molecule
has risks because it's a pharmaceutical
it has a package insert I do want to
talk about fruits in a moment but first
in your book you have this concept of
carnivore ich yeah and to me it's like
the palatable way for folks who are
trying to improve their health maybe
they have an autumn
in condition or maybe they have
inflammation or they're just not feeling
very good and they need to take on some
sort of elimination diet what is
carnivore ish carnivore a shoes I think
where most people are gonna find their
sweet spot it's making animal foods a
large portion of your diet realizing
that you get a lot of nutrients from
animal foods and then thinking about
plants on a spectrum of toxicity and
excluding the plants that are the most
toxic or the plants that trigger you the
most and so this is all kind of new
thinking it's kind of new hypothesis in
the book I offer what my opinion is
regarding which are the most toxic
plants and a spectrum a plant toxicity
on the mower toxic side I think of
things like seeds because those are the
seed the plant babies they're highly
defended in terms of anti-nutrients
digestive enzyme inhibitors London's
right so she's like if Ryan is eating
some sunflower seeds that's right that's
not good it's probably those have lots
of the plant anti nutrients in them and
will probably cause lots of digestive
issues what others leads are ven so
seeds is actually a broad botanical term
which includes grains seeds and nuts and
legumes they're all plant seeds right
we're trying to plant babies maybe in
the book I should have call them plant
babies right I plant babies don't eat
plant babies if you have issues right
they're so tender and delicious they're
probably the most immuno genic things
out there do you eat anything other than
animal-based products so is there
anything that doesn't come from an
animal in your diet negative all right
salt
oh yeah that comes from the earth okay
so there are minerals you do yeah yep so
what a mayonnaise you do minerals and
you do any supplements I know there any
supplements right now okay hey I noticed
you don't drink coffee I don't drink
coffee
sue me you don't drink alcohol then
either I don't drink alcohol it doesn't
really serve me okay find it to be
beneficial
is there a Billy enough without it yeah
yeah is there a is there a health
benefit to not drinking coffee I believe
there is and I know my good friend Ben
Greenfield and I might disagree on this
there's a whole section in the book
about a coffee when he was here he was
like chewing nicotine I love then I love
that's good to have you know different
idea really is it really so when the
cups of coffee yeah when it comes to
coffee so coffees a seed right oh yeah
it's not only a seed it's a being it to
see the same thing yeah coffee
plant baby it's a roasted plant baby so
in the book you get I talked about
acrylamide which is pretty much
considered a carcinogen happens when you
roast things and you Brown them plant
pesticides perhaps we're drinking
amazing organic coffee here which is
gonna have lower pesticides if coffees
not wet process there can be mycotoxins
which appear to be damaging for humans
and then coffee itself contains
molecules Kathak acid chlorogenic acid
which are polyphenolic and in the book I
talked about this the polyphenols many
of the polyphenols when they're studied
especially coffee polyphenols have been
shown to break DNA in cell culture ways
is this question you know like how much
of what we're doing is good for us and
how much what we're doing is actually
harming us and that's why I try to frame
it from the perspective of you're buried
in the sand
you're making toxins right do we really
think these things are good for us and
then we're a the risks and the benefits
is the benefit of coffee maybe it this
is true for some people maybe people
enjoy coffee enough to outweigh the
risks yeah but for me it's like it's a
black liquid my breath smells kind of
funny my teeth get kind of dark and it
doesn't give me any nutrients at all and
I believe the polyphenols to be
dangerous and I don't think that we need
them so I avoid coffee so again like the
side effects outweigh the the benefits
interesting do duties I don't do tea no
green tea or anything catechins and
green tea that have been found to
negatively affect enzymatic screen to be
so good for us heart disease and heart
attacks and people live longer who drink
green tea
epidemiology right yeah man oh wow
epidemiology is a carnivore issue so the
seeds are some of the worst things that
we can eat what are the other the other
big toxins then I do a for a saccas mr.
broccoli here okay brassicas I mean Dave
Asprey says broccoli is the best thing
to eat though you've asked we need to
have a wrestling match around broccoli
what else so what's on the other side of
the the spectrum of carnivore ish that
is that is a a bit healthier if you're
going to intelligence yeah so I'll just
tell you I can tell you all the things
that are on the toxic side then we'll go
to the other side so we got the seeds
the Brassica vegetables high oxalate
foods and so high oxalate foods would be
like almonds and and the the spinach and
also sweet potatoes maybe a toes are
moderate oxalate beads white not as much
but white potatoes are in nightshade
okay so then the night shades and that's
the more toxic things okay really the
least toxic side and this is just kind
of broad strokes right sure it's gonna
be individual but I do think things like
oxalate are probably harmful in most
humans the other side of the equation is
I think the least toxic things are non
sweet fruits so fruits are generally the
plants a it's their plants best shot
it's the pin-up girl they put in the
window that says hey look at me I'm sexy
come eat me they're not gonna put a lot
of toxins in the fruit and they might
put toxins in the seeds that are in the
fruit so that the animal doesn't really
eat the seeds or because that's what
they want that plant wants the animal to
get rid of the seed to plant it
somewhere else in a very nice fertile
yeah right yeah right yeah and they want
the seeds to come out of the animal
undigested right so they're of akkad OHS
then avocados olives squash some of the
non Brassica lettuces so like romaine
lettuce romaine lettuce kale Oh kale is
Brassica Cobra yeah romaine lettuce
berries are probably less sweet and then
berries and blueberries strawberries
raspberries he's probably less toxic
fruits in my opinion and then in the
middle I put tubers you know and and
beets of course are high in oxalate so I
would put like sweet potatoes in the
middle white potatoes are nightshades
those are probably gonna be a little
more immunogenic so sweet potatoes in
the middle and then a genic means what
triggering for our immune system cuz
that's really what we're talking about
here right in our gut we have all of
this interface between all the foods we
eat and the immune system there's one
cell layer the endothelium that
separates all the foods we eat from
trillions of immune cells just waiting
to pounce on anything right we have a
zoo
army just sitting there hmm and if you
poke the army you don't to piss the army
off right there are I think this is a
very reasonable hypothesis for
autoimmune disease that it's coming from
the gut that it's coming from activation
of immune cells in the gut and so that
is immunologic tolerance and immunologic
activation we're gonna dive a lot more
into the gut ryan real quick we should
move on to the lightning round it is
time for the lightning round where we
answer your text messages you can text
your questions and comments to nine
three seven two zero two four six five
for those texts go straight to both of
our phones we can't answer every
question but we will reply to as many as
possible they really do go to both of
our phones and also a lot of people just
constantly like remember we were
responding it's almost like I don't
believe it's you I have trust issues we
just like took a selfie and send it to
ya so Ryan and I were in Salt Lake City
last week finishing the soundtrack for
our next film les is now and we did an
impromptu meet up with just our text
group of people is we just send out a
day before we send out a text said hey
meet us at this coffee shop and almost a
hundred people showed up crazy in Salt
Lake City and thankfully we recorded it
so if you're a patreon supporter well
actually we'll share that with the folks
who are on patreon but during the
lightning round this is where Ryan and I
and now Paul do our best to answer every
question was just a short shareable less
than 140 character response we also put
the text of these minimal Maxim's in the
show notes so you can copy and share our
pit the answers on social media if you
like and now you can find all of our
minimal Maxim's in one place minimal
Maxim's com oh and that that meetup we
did it's got an unscripted meetup we're
gonna do that in some other cities
coming up so if you want you can sign up
for our text group just send us the tax
ninety three seven two oh two four six
five four indeed our question here is
from Jessica what is inflammation and
why is it so difficult to determine
what's healthy so we have two questions
here Paul and really we can monitor on a
little bit here but I've you've
explained inflammation very succinctly
in a way that I've never had a doctor
explain it to me so I thought this was a
perfect question for you that to answer
the inflammation is activation of the
immune system and it can be good or it
can be bad we need inflammation to heal
wounds we need information to fight
diseases but sometimes our immune system
gets triggered unnecessarily and
chronically so inflammation often has a
negative connotation but it can be a
very good thing in the body but it's the
way I think of it is activation of the
immune system is inflammation it is a
cytokine milieu which is all a whole
bunch of immune cells text messaging
each other saying there's a clean up on
aisle five you know there's an invader
you know there's an invaders blue
invaders you know and so that's that's
generally what inflammation is all the
immune cells kind of sending out signals
to each other that something is going
wrong and something needs to be done
mm-hmm okay and so her question here is
why is it so difficult to determine
what's healthy I think we've already
talked about that a little bit we've
there's a message has been propagated
throughout the media and I think that
the intentions here by the way are
really good and and when I see the
healthiest people in my life they're
almost all omnivores it's with the
exception of rich role yeah everyone
else I know is some sort of eats both
animal products and and plants right
yeah I'm thinking of dr. Ryan green
who's been on our podcast for one of
healthiest people I know yeah mostly
plant-based my wife Rebecca is mostly
plant-based with yet has some animal
products in her diet and so we are told
that you know healthy is one thing but
why is it so difficult to determine
what's healthy my pithy answer is just
health is perspectival and I think for
each of us it's like saying athletic
right like I can be the most athletic
version of myself but I'm never going to
be LeBron James and I think the same is
true with with health it's it's what is
healthy for you what is most appropriate
for you and I think there's a bit of a
perspective there although I think Paul
would argue that there's maybe a
foundation upon which we can build I
mean I totally agree with you Josh cuz
like so my wife she has a lot of gut
issues and she tried to do like full
carnivore I mean maybe like I don't know
a few days it wasn't it wasn't you know
consistent this six-week test it wasn't
this elimination diet per se but right
away like in the first three day she's
like Ryan this isn't like this isn't
working for me I have to have some
carbohydrates in my diet so I you know I
guess I don't know if she's doing it
wrong and she needs to give it longer of
a chance but to Josh's point it's like
you could be carnivore you're one of the
healthiest dudes I've ever seen like
your skin is clear you got veins popping
out you're probably 60 years old dude
you look like you're 20
but like rich Rome and he's you know in
his 50s right yeah yeah and he and he
looks younger than me and he's and he's
a vegan so - Josh this point I do feel
like health is this respectable thing
where it depends on how your how your
genes are built and like what your DNA
is really built for even though we look
the same we got ears nose eyes mouth
we're the same species our genes still
are affected differently with different
foods our genes are
acted differently with different foods
and I believe that there is a
fundamental ancestral human diet and I
you know and I told this to rich when he
was here I think rich would be even more
of a monster if he ate meat you know so
how do you know how interesting how do
you know how good you can be if you're
eating that way rich maybe one of the
small amount of people in this world in
this universe who is able to detoxify
all these plant toxins been able to use
the nutrients in them well I think the
majority people can't do that and the
animal foods are the foundational thing
for most people now I think there is
some genetic variation in terms of how
many plant foods we can tolerate which
ones will be more sensitive to our
systems than others but the message that
I'm hoping to share is that if people
are not well if they are having
autoimmune disease if they are having an
inflammation imagine or realize that
plant foods could be the trigger there
there's so much messaging now go more
plant-based take meat out well you can
try that but if that doesn't work plants
could be caused by so problems because
of all the problems yeah so do you have
a talk offline about what was going on
here why yeah serious yeah well I mean
you know just anecdotally like do you
think she should just keep keep pushing
through the discomfort that she's
experienced what was she experienced
she's saying I need more carbohydrates
what does that mean to her is she having
diarrhea yeah so I don't know the
details of that so yeah maybe we will
I'll get some more information and maybe
a talk to you offline on many times when
people transition from a carbohydrate
centric diet to a diet that is lower
carb they're going to go through
biochemical changes there is keto flu
there's a drop and insulin people are
going to need more electrolytes there
are all kinds of things that can happen
to us as we transition so it depends
what she's experiencing there and I
think we could probably walk through
that whether it was a GI thing or sort
of feeling there is biochemical changes
that happen um as we transition off
carbohydrates and I'll just add that
evolutionarily I just don't think we've
had that many carbohydrates in our diet
because I have 300 to 400 grams of carbs
a day is it's pretty much impossible in
the natural world and I think that being
in ketosis is probably our default state
but so many of us have never been there
so we go there for the first time it's
like the first time you go to Morocco
you're like a nerve in Morocco right
mm-hmm a lot of people have never been
in ketosis ville yeah ketosis Ville is a
different place yeah used to and you
have to take a plane to ketosis villains
turbulent talk about all the benefits of
he ptosis and and and also cycling in
and now we've got a lot more to talk
about when you've got a yeah my pit the
answer to that to Jessica's question
there is health is a journey not a
destination and I think so many people
and we'll talk about this during the
podcast you know people focus on why I
want to lose weight or you know I want
to have big veins popping out of my out
of my arms and then they get to that
point well to stay at that point like
you still have to continue down that
road of health so yes health is not a
destination it is a journey alright
before we get into our added value
segment and our listener tips today
looks like we got a bunch more to
discuss this week including cholesterol
carbohydrates gluten sugar fructose
processed foods toxins and plant toxins
and allergies and food sensitivities and
why we get them and what to do about
them we're also gonna talk about
autoimmune issues skin issues acne
depression mental illness oh and
supplements I have a pocketful of
supplements we'll talk about the ethics
behind eating meat I think that's an
important discussion that we need to
dive into also some of the best foods
for the gut microbiome and what we
understand about the microbiome and what
we don't understand
also maybe we can make an argument for a
plant-based diet and so much more with
dr. Paul Saladino oh we've got this
article - can babies learn to love
vegetables oh and we're gonna talk about
weight loss as well and if you want to
hear all that listen to this week's
maximal episode that's right you're
currently listening to our weekly
minimal episode but each week Ryan and I
record an entirely different much longer
much more personal maximal episode on
the minimalist private podcast which
gives us the private space we need to
talk about topics we don't usually
discuss in public plus it's the bus wait
for us to fund this podcast and keep it
100% advertisement free when you
subscribe to the minimalist private
podcast on patreon you'll receive a
personal link so that our maximal
episodes play in your favorite podcast
app find all the details over at the
minimalists com slash support Ryan what
else you got for us this week here are
some voicemail comments and tips from
our listeners check them out hi my name
is Jordan and I'm calling from Brooklyn
New York I had an idea regarding
minimizing baby stuff in regards to a
questions that appeared on both
parenting episode I find it incredibly
hard still to get rid of anything that
has my baby's name on it
he's almost one year old but I do find
that with time and as he becomes more
ingrained in our lives it gets easier
and I don't feel that I need to hold on
to every single thing so my idea is that
in in in line with the minimalists
attitude in general to revisit thing
every few months I kind of take a look
at the things that I've kept around
cards that we got when he was born
little gifts that we never used stuff
like that and every few months I find
that I can get rid of a couple more
things that don't actually add that much
value or mean that much anymore so you
know it's kind of an ongoing process
it's not a one-stop shop but it works
hello my name is Nadia and I'm from
Denver Colorado with spring cleaning
around the corner I have a tip to share
on ethical recycling of unwanted
clothing items there's an online
consignment store called thread up where
you can recycle your clothes for cash
credit or donation one of the best
things that we can do for our planet is
to consume less but if we're going to
consume buying secondhand is a great
option so here's how it works you can
order a kit from their website at
wwlp.com
send it off they do all the work they
inspect the clothing they take pictures
and they sell it for you and you can
either get cash back or credit to their
store to use on items that you may need
or you can choose a charity of your
choice to donate your proceeds to which
is personally my favorite option and the
best part is that whatever doesn't sell
they will ethically recycle those items
for you they're a great company to
collaborate with with a wonderful
philosophy on making a positive impact
on our planet which is if more people
were secondhand clothing items that
would mean less waste and if everyone in
the u.s. bought just one item used
instead of something new this year it
would save nearly 6 billion pounds of
carbon emissions all right Joe
thanks again to dr. Paul Saladin indeed
I would encourage you to check out his
book it's called the carnivore code you
can also find him online at carnivore MD
comm and his podcast the fundamental
health podcast we'll put a link to all
that in the show notes as well as his
youtube channel and his social media you
can find him over there he's always
doing a lot of pretty wild things on
social media real quick for right here
right now here's one thing that's going
on in the life of the minimalists well
it's almost the end of February at this
point and the 24th and the 25th we're
opening up enrollment for my writing
class so direct good words
could you write more gooder than you
write right now it's so so you can
download the free ebook it's 11 ways to
write better over at how to write better
org you can also sign up for the email
list when you do that and we will notice
notify you the first hundred people can
sign up for my writing class I tend to
offer this two or three times a year and
I believe the rising tide lifts all
boats so I've had medical doctors take
this class I've had high school students
take this class I've had folks who are
english-as-a-second-language take this
class you can you can really you give me
4 weeks of your life and I will show you
how to write better I will give you a
little bit of a warning though it is it
does require some work if you can't
dedicate an hour a day it's probably not
for you and that's okay you can still
get all of my free writing tips over it
there at how to write better org but if
you give me four weeks I can help you
write better for sure you can follow the
minimalists on facebook twitter and
instagram at the minimalists if you have
a question comment or minimalism tip for
our podcast email a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists com comment
on this episode at youtube.com slash the
minimalists if you want our show notes
in your inbox sign up for our e-mail
list over the minimalists comm you also
receive our simple Sunday emails each
week Ryan for our added value this week
let's listen to a new song from Noah
Gunderson ooh he's gonna be with this
pretty soon on tour yeah we're going on
the LES Coast tour he'll be with us in
Seattle he won't be our musical guest
but he will be our podcast guest in
Seattle and he has this new acoustic
album out called a raven and a dove and
this is kamikaze from that album and if
you leave here today with just one
message we hope it's this love people
and use things because the opposite
never works thanks for listen y'all
we'll see you next time and minimus
[Laughter]